it is time for you to call in to win  james taylor tickets for his show this  weekend all you have to do is be the  eighth caller call 702-792-8801  good luck yeah you know i've seen fire  and i've seen rain but i don't know if  i've seen a giveaway like this one it's  gonna be good that is the one to go to  there's so much going on in town this  weekend but man james taylor who wants  to miss classic right no  good stuff and your favorite is uh fire  and rain yeah that is a great one but  you were singing them i mean i was  literally getting a kendall tennessee  serenade oh and yeah  yeah and it's lucky she's still here  because usually that clears a room  everybody have a great day thank you so  much for joining us i'm gonna continue  the serenade okay i'll do a little  singing okay we'll put it on tick tock  yes now tick tock is valuable he's on it  [Music]  you